Deaths from overdose in the United States increased by 2.2 times more than in 2002
To 2015
But what is the most dangerous drug in the world?
If we refer to the most lethal substances, scientists use the so-called
"LDL" or LD50, which measures the required amount of the substance
To kill half of the organs tested
For example, 30 g of coffee kills a person weighing 70 kg, while
This amount is much lower to reach 0.00175 cm of terrestrial Typhoon.
Using this method, the most lethal substances on Earth are
Botulinum toxin, or botox
In the case of oral ingestion, the dose that is required to kill a person weighing 70 kg is 0.00000007 g.
However, the "most dangerous" does not always mean "the deadliest".
A group of experts in the UK decided to find out the most common "hazard" caused by this recreational property
Using 16 variables including the types of social, psychological and physical harm.
For example, this medicine may cause physical damage but is non lethal, and can cause it to become
Continue entirely, in addition to being more likely to lose relationships or lack
Mental performance, these are all forms of "damage".
Through these criteria it was concluded that the most dangerous drug on the individual is heroin
Heroin can be taken by injection, inhalation, or smoking in addition to it reaches the brain quickly
When injected into the bloodstream.
When used, it is related to the quasi-opioid receptors, which in turn create a wave of pleasurable sensations.
In addition, this substance causes addiction accompanied by severe withdrawal symptoms that begin in a matter of hours
From substance abuse, these symptoms include insomnia, colds, muscle and bone pain, nausea and vomiting.
The receptors present in the brain stem are also affected, affecting important physiological processes
Such as breathing and blood pressure.
Excessive doses therefore slow the breathing process or stop it altogether, leading to an accumulation
CO2 gas in the blood and eventually cause death.
Since it is difficult for heroin users to know the strength of the dose is because it is not specified
Which increases the chances of overdose.
In addition, this drug can be mixed with other compounds such as fentanyl, making the drug more
Risk.
Both fentanyl and heroin are similar because they are opioids, but the strength of fentanyl is 50-100 times stronger than heroin,
Lipid which means it penetrates fat in the brain more easily.
With regard to the amount of harm he will inflict is more dangerous than heroin.
It was initially used as a pain reliever but because of its addiction,
It was used for late cases.
Since its emergence as a recreational drug, the number of cases has increased
Users of doses of 7 x more than 2012 to 2014 in the United States, and this article is still widely used
Worldwide.
But there is a more dangerous anesthetic than that!
Although cocaine and methamphetamine are at the forefront of harmful substances on the individual but they still come
Heroin, finding the most dangerous drug involves studying 20 different types of drugs,
In addition to knowing the damage caused by this drug to others.
This includes psychological and physical harm, crime and family and community disintegration
And economic costs - and eventually it became clear that the most dangerous drug in the world is ...
Alcohol.
To make sure that this is not just a phenomenon in the UK, a European group has established the same process
With a greater focus on damage to the individual and less on economic damage.
Even with the different weights in two groups of alcohol the result was very similar.
The use of alcohol on a large scale increases its severity.
Most people in the world consume (61.7%) a lot of drink with an average of 17 liters
Of the pure alcohol used by the individual in general.
The World Health Organization (WHO) has reported that worldwide deaths of 3.3 million people have been reported
Dangerous consumption of alcohol in 2012 which means that alcohol kills one person every 10 seconds.
But experts did not recommend banning alcohol.
But in all cases the war on drugs has failed, and the countries that have been spared
Follow strict policies and implement non-criminalization, harm reduction, and awareness-raising
Have seen a marked decline in drug abuse.
If you want to know more about the failure of the war on drugs, check out the video content on A Nutshell
Who helped us add animation effects to this video!
Many thanks for helping us and continuing to inspire us with their intelligence
And their wonderful design for the video.
You can also check out the string that talks about the drug so in case you want to learn more about the effect
A specific anesthetic on the brain such as marijuana, cocaine, or lsd
Subscribe to receive more educational videos every week!